حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
منظومات الدفاع الجوي اسقطت 44 مسيره
اوكرانيه في يوم واحد واشارت الوزاره الى
اسقاط مسيره اوكرانيه في مقاطعه موسكو
ومسيارتين اخرىين في منطقه ابراج موسكو
سيتي بوسط العاصمه واعلنت سلطات الطوارئ
اصابه شخص نتيجه اصطدام مسيره باحد
الابراج وقالت ان حركه الطيران عادت
لطبيعتها في كل المطارات بعد اغلاق المجال
الجوي مؤقتا فوق العاصمه الروسيه
كما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه التعرض
لهجوم وصفته بالارهابي
بطائره استهدف شبه جزيره القرم وقالت
الوزاره في بياننا الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت
25 طائره مسيره اوكرانيه ان الهجوم لم
يسفر عن اي ضحايا او اصابات
في المقابل اعلنت القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه انها تعرضت لهجوم روسي خلال
الليله الماضيه باربع طائرات مسيره من
الجنوب الشرقي الى البلاد مشيره الى تدمير
اربع مسيرات روسيه في اتجاه خرسون ودنيبرو
خلال اليوم الماضي